-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress
you know
from her work in "Black-ish."
Her holiday movie,
"Candy Cane Lane,"
is streaming now on Prime Video.
She also stars
in "American Fiction,"
which opens in select theaters
December 15th
and nationwide in January.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Tracee Ellis Ross,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello.
-You look fantastic,
and it's very important to me
that you look fantastic.
-Why is that?
-Because I'm coming up
on a milestone birthday that
you passed last year.
-Oh, I'm so deep
in the 50s now. I'm 51.
-Yeah.
-I can tell you all about it.
-Are you loving it?
-I love it so much.
-Oh, that's great.
I have to say,
I've always loved getting older,
but there's something
really spectacular
about getting to an age
where you feel really
comfortable saying "no."
You feel comfortable
just sort of going,
"Yeah, that
doesn't really work for me."
Or, "You know what?
I'm not feeling that."
Or, "Yeah, I want to do that."
-That's great.
Everything you just said,
I'm so excited to try on my wife
and have not work.
-Maybe it works
because I'm single.
-It's still good.
-It feels really good.
I'm glad to have you
feel so enthusiastic about it.
-Yeah, I mean,
there's some things
that are absolutely
odd, weird, and strange.
Like sometimes when you wake up
in the morning,
you're like, did I sleep or did
somebody beat me up? Not sure.
-Because you're just,
that deep soreness.
-You get out of bed
and you're like, [ Groans ].
Sometimes if I ended up
sleeping on my stomach
and I turn over, I'm like, "Oh,
God, I think I'm paralyzed."
And then --
-The worst about that is,
yeah, when you do that
and somebody's like,
"Oh, were you working out?"
And you're like, "No."
-"Not at all."
No, I slept.
-Slept weird.
-Had a good night's sleep.
Sorry. Let me just move my hair.
Okay. Go ahead.
-Alright, well, I'll look out
for all of those things.
-And are you going to have
a big celebration?
Everybody does different things.
I actually did something big
for my birthday.
-You did, huh?
-It was pretty special.
Speeches and the whole thing.
I might as well have been
a wedding.
-See, that's wonderful.
-It was nice.
-See, I'm not going to do that.
-No?
But everybody
has a different version.
-My problem is just
where it falls.
It's December 28th,
so it's like,
nobody is ready for a party.
-You're a December 28th baby?
-Yeah, yeah.
-That is tough.
-It's the worst.
I feel like because
of where it landed,
they should only count
every other one,
and I'm about to be 25.
-I'm game.
I think during the pandemic,
none of those years happened.
-Yeah, right?
-No, I'm actually 48.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Yeah.
-Well, then
we don't even have to
worry about
that big birthday
for a couple of years.
Doesn't matter.
-You have time
to work on your speeches.
-I'm gonna have another one.
-Now, you did a holiday movie?
-I did a holiday movie.
-And you have
a big family yourself.
-I do.
-And are the holidays...
-There's five kids.
They're all married with kids
and just grandbabies
and just uncles and aunts
and just people
running all over each other.
-Do you love the chaos?
-I do.
-Okay, and you always have?
-I always have.
And then I have somehow
created this very serene,
quiet life for myself,
so I go into the chaos,
and then I come out into
my little, quiet world, yeah.
-Do you serve a very
valuable purpose as someone
who maybe has energy reserves
that the parents don't have?
-Well,
the most important purpose
that I serve with my family,
to the point that I'm not going
home for Christmas this year
and my mom literally was like,
"But who's going
to make the salads?
No, we're going to miss you,
but who's going
to make the salads?"
-So your mother, Diana Ross,
doesn't have
a backup salad person?
-No, it's me.
We sat together for a second,
really thinking, like,
"Would Ross make the salads?
Would Evan?"
No, no one makes the salad.
I make the salads."
-Wow. You're gonna
have to FedEx salads.
-I'm usually in charge of food
when I'm home.
-God, they really
take advantage of you.
-Well, everyone else
has kids running around.
-Yeah, yeah, that's true.
-I'm like,
yeah, so I do salads.
-You did this film --
-I cook food too,
but I'm particularly good
with the salads.
I'm sorry.
-I love that you're like,
"I'm a bit of a chef."
"What do you do?"
-"Salads."
-You did this
holiday movie with Eddie Murphy.
-Eddie Murphy!
-That's amazing.
-Yes!
[ Cheering ]
-I mean, three months
with Eddie Murphy.
-Three months, and we had a ball
and did not exhaust
all the stories
that had to be told.
And we would go tit for tat.
We would just keep trying to see
who could do a better story.
And it was a ball.
-So you've lived
a fascinating life,
that you're willing to go
tit for tat with Eddie Murphy.
-I was like, "Get me in here,
get me in here.
Oh, yeah, you? Oh, yeah, really?
Oh, Stevie Wonder?
Oh, let me tell you
about Stevie Wonder."
-Oh, that's real good.
-It was really good.
-That's real good.
-Had you met him before?
-No.
-Okay, wow.
-Bizarre, never met him.
First day of work,
my first day of work,
I'm like, "Okay, well,
I'm going to meet Eddie Murphy."
-Yeah.
-So he's like a cat.
He's very quiet.
You don't know he's coming.
So he kind of walked up to me
and he said,
"Tracee Ellis Ross?"
And I was like, okay,
we're bowing, alright.
I was like, "Eddie Murphy."
-Yeah, of course.
And then I sat and I asked him,
I was like, "Are there things
that you need, like,
that I need to know?
Like, am I allowed to talk
while you're acting? Can I...?"
He was like,
"What are you talking about?"
And I was like, "Well,
I've worked with actors
where, you know, you can't."
And then I said,
"And how do I address you?
Do I call you Eddie, Mr.
Schmurphy? What's the scoop?"
And he was like, "Eddie."
And I said, "Great."
And then we were
just off to the races.
That's fantastic.
-It was really good.
-Do you feel
like you're a little tired
of the holidays
because you had to pretend it
was Christmas for three months?
-It's not because of the movie.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-No, I love the holiday season,
but I also am a person
who doesn't do a tree.
-Yeah.
-Because then
you have to take it down, so...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Tell me about it.
-I mean, get it organized.
-That's what I say
every year when they put up that
30 Rock tree.
I'm like,
"What are you guys doing?"
-Guys, then got to take it down.
What are you doing?
-You think this part's hard?
-Pshh.
Taking down the tree
is so hard.
-Imagine that one!
-Oh, my God.
-The dumbest thing in the world.
-Do not sign me up.
-Do not sign me up!
I have a lot more
to ask you about,
because you have
a lot of projects right now.
Tracee Ellis Ross, we'll
be right back after this.